il y a très longtemps le monde des
humains et le monde des démons ét
relié y qui s'inilt dans le monde des
humains trouit beaucoup trop
rapidement il une puissance démoniaque
derrière tout
ça je te donneon prier ordantc DEES
certain tu n'auras aucune raison de
refuser Cohen mat a trouvé un mentor je
suis convaincu que ça va
t'aider
attaque-moi il doit juste ressentir avec
son
corps tu es le diable deviens fort Yuk
de cette manière tu pourras protéger
ceux auquel tu
tiens tu dois êtreé corama le coursier
du monde des esprits j'ai le terrible
pressentiment qu'on nous attendu un
tracenard à tous les trois mais yokai
c'est pas ce qui brûl des villes sans
que ça les
dérange moi ça me va on va enfin pouvoir
s'amuser en toute
liberté plus moyen de revenir en arrière
maintenant je vais m' charger on va
commencer par un petit
[Musique]
échauffement
je remets entre vos mains le sort de
[Musique]
l'humanité de la pure
énergie je suis pas pareil que toi tu
penses être fort mais c'est pas le
cas plus besoin d'avoir d'amis ou de
famille autour de
toi
pistoletu
ah